whether you're in a rut with your
training or even it is there are aspects
missing from your fitness and
performance the right training tools can
make a huge difference in your workouts
while ideally we'd be able to get a
complete workout using only our own
bodies it's also true that there are
some things you simply can't achieve
without the right tools there's no
substitute to squatting under a heavy
barbell for instance with that in mind
the right tools can be fantastic for
challenging yourself in new and
interesting ways to force your body to
adapt and to make your workouts more
very interesting and challenging the
thing is if you look at most home gyms
all someone's gonna have is a pair
dumbbells and maybe a barbell and even
when we go to the gym to Train will
often just stick to the dumbbells and
the barbells you might get the odd
person who loves kettlebell training in
the right that's their world and they do
loads of kettlebell training or maybe
you'll get someone who just loves
bodyweight training and they do loads of
modes of calisthenics but I think
there's a huge benefit in combining all
these different types of training in
order to get all the different types of
performance all the different types of
strength in order to do that using lots
of different types of equipment can be a
really good method and so this video I'm
going to break down some of my favorite
training equipment some of my favorite
training tools that I use regularly in
order to train across as many
disciplines and modalities as possible
if you want to learn more about any of
this stuff then check out the link in
the description down below to the
written version of this video there
you'll also be able to find links to all
the different products and you also find
a link to my ebook and training program
down there super functional training
that's all about training in different
ways and combining different disciplines
in order to make your workouts more
awesome so if you like this then I think
that'll be right up your street
fat gripz are an example of something is
simple yet highly effective these are
essentially grips that you can attach to
a dumbbell kettlebell barbell or even a
pull-up bar in order to make the handles
slightly wider the result is that it's
tougher to grip onto said bar and you
therefore get more benefit for your grip
from any exercise these are small enough
to throw in a bag and to bring to the
gym and they come in a variety of
different sizes you can also get
knockoff variants which are a little bit
cheaper a weighted vest is a fantastic
tool for increasing the challenge on any
body weight move this can also be
extremely useful for progressing and
achieving more difficult calisthenics
moves for example if you're trying to
get the muscle up and then performing
explosive weighted pull-ups is a great
way to do that weighted vests are also
increase the cardiovascular challenge of
nearly any activity go for a walk and
throw on a vest and you'll burn more
calories just here's the still bow from
bull worker which they very kindly sent
me full disclosure
when you get to 100,000 subscribers it
turns out people send you loads of free
stuff this is a device for training with
isometrics and specifically overcoming
isometrics that means that you're
pushing or pulling against an immovable
force in this case you can push it you
can pull it you've got these straps and
it's built sturdily so that it won't
break and you can give it your all the
reason we do this is that it's very
similar as far as your neural Drive is
concerned to try and lift more than your
one rep max in other words you can
improve your muscle fiber recruitment
and this could lead to strength gains
this is a technique that was extremely
popular with old-time strongmen and bull
Walker has been around an awfully long
time I particularly like this thing
because it's really small and light you
can throw it into a bag nice and easily
you'll hold each static contraction for
about 6 seconds rest and then repeat and
you want to train ideally at 3 different
joint angles in order to make sure that
you cover the full range of motion on
any given exercise or movement a club
Bell not to be mistaken for this
slightly lighter and with an Indian club
is a large heavy Club that you can swing
around and lift in a similar manner to a
kettlebell like a kettlebells the center
of gravity is offset away from the
handle the difference here is the way
you grip the club and actually the lever
is also slightly longer that you have
the option to choke your hand up and
down the handle to alter the amount of
resistance you want to work with club
bells are fantastic for developing core
muscles and balance as your body fights
against the momentum and the constantly
changing angles
resistance they're excellent for your
grip and they also help to open up the
joints in the shoulders for developing
mobility and joint strength but the
kettlebell is probably still the Don
when it comes to weirdly shaped dumbbell
alternatives kettlebells are useful for
training strength for angles you can't
easily hit with a barbell and for a
range of movements such as the Turkish
getup kettlebells also lend themselves
very well to explosive full body
movements especially using the legs and
this makes them a great alternative to a
barbell on a rack when you don't have
the space finally thanks to the momentum
you can build it with a kettlebell and
keep going they're actually ideal for
metabolic conditioning combining
resistance training with cardio next up
resistance bands resistance bands could
be used for all kinds of different types
of training I've lately been using mine
just for mobility stuff like shoulder
dislocates the great thing about
resistance bands you can stick them in
your pocket or you can tie onto a door
handle and you can literally use them
anywhere of course they can be used to
provide a small amount of resistance for
certain exercises which don't require
particularly heavy weights you can use
resistance bands to provide assistance
in a range of different exercises
particularly bodyweight exercises such
as pull ups or planche or rows or you
can use them to make your movements more
difficult by providing additional
resistance or accommodating resistance
accommodating resistance means that the
weight gets heavier as it gets closer to
the point where you're strongest so for
instance in the bench press by attaching
resistance bands to the bar and then to
the ground it becomes heavier as you
push it up training masks came under
some flak for false advertising the
problem was that they didn't really
offer the simulated high-altitude that
they often promised in marketing that
doesn't make them useless in fact
training master or some tools for
training and developing the respiratory
muscles such as the intercostals and the
diaphragm that we use for taking an
oxygen they can therefore help to
improve our vo2 max and work capacity
not to mention increasing calorie burn
during training studies show this can
improve cognitive performance over time
by improving oxygen supply to the brain
a similar device is the inspiratory
muscle trainer this is a small device
that you stick in your mouth so you can
use it whilst you're typing or doing
anything else see you my content on
Aquaman training for more on this using
dip bars and parallettes allows you to
work on movements such as planche and
handstand press ups using a neutral
wrist position stronger grip on the
ground and greater clearance for moving
your legs this makes those move slightly
easier to learn and sustain in turn
allows you to develop advanced
calisthenics skills learning moves like
the planche and its various progressions
is something I highly recommend even if
you never accomplish these feats you'll
develop a lot of body awareness mobility
and strength simply from trying dip bars
and power let's are an entire gym that
fits in the corner of your room actually
leave my dip bars in my study my bio lab
whenever the computers loading I just
want to take five I'll go and do some
dips or some tuck planche presses and
this is a great way for me to grease the
groove at the same time is just moving
all the time which I talked about in my
last video as being extremely important
dip bars in particular very versatile
because you can also use it for pulling
movements like inverted press ups even
things like front leavers if you hang
off just one bar gymnastics rings are
rings that hang from a bar a set of dip
bars or anything else in order to allow
you to use a range of movements such as
dips ring push-ups ring pull-ups
bodyweight rows inverted push-ups
various support holds and much more
hang them higher up and you can even
practice things like ring muscle ups the
Iron Cross or Maltese rings require a
huge amount of control and strength as
you'll be forced to balance at the same
time as performing pushing and pressing
movements they also again allow you to
train at unusual angles and positions
that will build strength and endurance
in connective tissue and help you work
towards more advanced skills because
they can be used for pulling or pushing
they're also among the most versatile
training tools you can purchase another
option that similar to gymnastic rings
is a rope a rope is one of the cheapest
things you can buy and it's fantastic
they're training all sorts of things I
bought a pull-up bar that has small
loops at the top then I also bought
myself carabiners and I loop them
through this rope which also had a metal
ring at the end and I was able to do
lots of rope climbing things like tricep
extensions bodyweight rows there's all
kinds of cool things you can do with a
rope rope climbing in particular is a
brilliant way to Train your grip
strength to train your bicep strength
elbow tendon strength your core and
there's a really practical movement that
actually mimics something that you might
want they have to do in a real-life
situation if you're ninja which is cool
that's what we're going for here
something else is extremely useful that
I think most people can benefit from to
some extent is a fitness tracker so
fitness trackers have lots of benefits
for one if you're trying to lose or gain
weight then being able to track roughly
your calorie expenditure and then
combine this with information from
something like My Fitness Pal to see how
many calories you're taking in it can be
really useful this is a estimate at best
but for most people it's gonna be
accurate enough to help them achieve
their goals I also think that a fitness
tracker is pretty much an absolute must
if you're interested in running or a
running watch of course so in this
regard a fitness tracker will allow you
to see progress you've got to measure
the distance that you run the speed that
you run you can measure your resting
heart rate but at the same time getting
a live update of your heart rate is
really useful if you're going to be
doing things like zone training so if
you want to stay within a certain heart
rate zone to burn calories or if you're
interested in doing a threshold run I
basically wouldn't recommend that anyone
get into running seriously without
having some kind of watch to track that
kind of stuff it'll also be useful of
course for things like sleep tracking
the aura ring is really good for that I
really like to have a fitness tracker
that also lets me install apps on it
I've got a time rack on there at the
moment well just swipe down once and
then it sets the timer for 30 seconds
this is extremely useful for instance
when I'm using isometric hold so if I
want to do a branch progression for
instance or if I'm trying crow pose or
handstands then I can just swipe up and
that time is ready to go wherever I may
be finally I'm gonna throw you a curve
ball the halo sport - this is another
device that I was sent recently to
review to try out and it's something
completely different that many of you
went fried basically this is a tDCS
device or a neuro primer
tDCS standing for transcranial direct
current stimulation essentially what
this does is it runs a small current a
small charge through your brain and the
idea is that it's increasing the resting
potential of your brain cells and so the
makers claim that this will allow you to
increase control during movements but
more specifically to learn new skills
and to increase your max strength
your technique more quickly it makes
your brain highly plastic the neurons
fire more easily but also with greater
strength and then they create
longer-lasting neural connections as a
result therefore if you tryna learn
something like a planche like handstand
presses but we want to improve your
punching technique in martial arts then
in theory this can help for lifters it's
very similar to be post activation
principle basically if you're trying to
lift something really heavy you then
find it easier to lift something lighter
that's because you've used those newer
connections and they're now primed and
more easy to access in the future I
think it would make sense to do this
with a coach you can make sure you're
using the correct technique therefore
you're more quickly learning the best
methods as for whether it actually works
I can't say with 100% certainty I
haven't been testing it long enough I'm
trying to use it to see if I can improve
my planche and body weight skills my
hand walking at the same time I'm trying
to see if I can use it to increase the
maximum number of pull-ups that I can do
and I'll let you guys know how that
turns out in future either in a video or
in an article on the website say stay
tuned if you want to hear more about
that so like I say not necessarily
recommending this just putting it in
here because it's really interesting and
cool and I want to talk about it we get
all that other stuff my higher they do
recommend the dip bars the power let's
the gymnastic rings the fat gripz
if you combine all these things together
you can create some extremely awesome
workouts as I said do anything wearing a
weighted vest and it becomes much more
difficult with miswrote climbing or ring
dips likewise if you strap on a training
mask you'll make it more of a cardio
workout wherever as you're doing with
these tools has limitless combinations
you can have a fun mess around and try
out different things your workouts
become far more inventive and
interesting and creative and you keep
your body adapting you prevent it from
becoming set in its ways by giving it
fresh new challenges every single day so
we found this video useful interesting
guys if you did then please leave a like
a comment down below and let me know
what your favorite training tools are of
course subscribe if you want more like
this and stay tuned for the next one
thanks a ton for watching and I'll see
you then
bye for now